[Music]
Rob's world hey what's up guys it's Rob
and welcome to my tutorial for the mini
origami boomerang which is based off my
original popular origami boomerang
tutorial for my last few video calls the
origami mini boomerangs at the top of
the list with thousands of votes and
also some comments saying they'd like me
to make a new version of the original
one since they were having trouble in
certain parts and also getting it to
work so I think the mini origami
boomerang would be a great spin on the
original one and also I'd go through it
in a lot of detail especially to some of
the parts that I think people were
having difficulty with like I mentioned
in my original origami video if you fold
the mini one correctly and practice how
to throw it it'll fly great as you'll
see here I even made a mini one from my
11 year old nephew and after some
practice he was able to catch it too so
check it out
just like with the regular size one you
can even overlap two of them together
and try to catch them at the same time
this requires a lot of practice but if
you get it you'll definitely be able to
impress your friends with this cool
trick shot with one piece of
eight-and-a-half by eleven letter size
printer paper you'll be able to make
four mini super boomerangs but you can
also follow along and make the regular
one if you want to so grab your paper
and let's make it do you want to make it
Lila to make the mini origami boomerang
I'm gonna split the paper into four
equal sheets by taking the top edge of
the paper folding it down to the bottom
and then creasing along that edge then I
run my fingernail against it or if you
want you to use scissors but I'm going
to open it up and split the paper in
half just like that then I'm gonna once
again take the top edge and fold it down
to the bottom and then make a crease
along that edge and once again crease it
with my fingernail open it up and then
tear it in half and then I'm ready to
make the mini boomerang if you'd like to
make the regular size one you could hold
a piece of paper like this fold it in
half lengthwise and then you can make a
nice crease along the top and give it a
good crease with your fingernail open it
up tear it in half then you can follow
along using the same direction I'm going
to show you for the many one starting
out we're going to take the top edge and
fold it down to the bottom edge and try
to line up the edges as neatly as
possible because neatness and also sharp
creases is very important for this model
once you line up the edges then you can
crease all the way across and then once
again I like to just run my fingernail
against it so that it's a nice sharp
crease then when you open up the paper
you'll see we've divided the paper in
half and we're going to take the top and
bottom edges and fold it directly next
to the line leaving a little bit of
space and I'll tell you why in a second
so just take the top edge fold it down
directly next to the line leaving about
a millimeter of space so just about that
much space right there
and the way I do that is I just fold it
down and press and then just work my
hand across making sure that it's about
even all the way across and then I just
crease it like that and do the same the
other direction then once again I just
make the crease nice and sharp so it
looks something like this
then flip it over and do the exact same
thing folding the edge down
and leaving a teeny bit of space between
the edge and the middle line then once
again make another sharp crease and the
reason that we left a little bit of
space is because we're going to
eventually fold these two edges together
and if they're too close you'll see that
they'll get crumpled up and not fold in
half once your paper looks like this
then we could take the left side and
we're going to fold it across to the
right side like this line up these two
edges now and then just hold them here
and we're just going to basically just
tug in here a little bit to round it off
and then we could just squeeze on this
edge here and crease it down just once
go over it with your fingernail now that
we have something like this holding the
open edges on the bottom like this we're
going to fold these two corners in like
an airplane directly on this middle
vertical line just take it and you could
just round it off a little like that and
fold it down so that this edge on top is
directly on that line just like this and
when you do that you'll see that the
bottom might become a little misaligned
so just try to make sure that they stay
aligned when you do that and then you
can make sure that that crease on top is
nice and firm so just press down on it
like that and then do the same with the
other top corner just round it off a
little fold it down and then just press
on it and then once again just go over
at one time with your fingernail so we
have something like that then we can
unfold these two top corners and you'll
see that we made those two creases right
there we're just going to take these
corners and fold them backwards on that
same crease we're just going to take it
and press back like this on that same
crease we just made and if you want
you'll see that it will line up with the
back vertical line too so just press on
it like that and crease it one time with
your fingernail and then do the same
with this one just fold it backwards on
that diagonal crease we made and then
just crease it then you could open up
the two corners once again making sure
the open edges are on the bottom we're
just going to hold it on the left side
of this vertical line like this and
we're going to take these two edges on
the right and we're just going to pull
them apart like this at the
and what you're going to do is you're
just going to press down on this corner
into the middle of the paper when you do
that you'll see a little triangle form
and we're just going to press on this
vertical line in the middle of the
triangle and then we could just take
these two corners and bring them
together and then just press on it right
here do the same with the left side just
hold on the right side of the paper now
open up these two edges once again when
you see that triangle just take your
finger and press in the middle and then
take these two edges and bring them
together like that and then once again
we're just going to crease on that new
fold that we just made so now you're
ready to move on to the next part at
this point we're now going to open
everything by taking this edge and just
lifting it up and just gently pulling on
everything and what we're going to do
now is take these two top corners and
we're going to airplane fold them in
just like we did before with these so
we're just going to take it so that this
edge is matched up with this one that we
folded in previously by folding it like
this rounding it off and lining it up
and then making a crease like that do
the same with the other edge the corner
goes all the way in like that and it
should be pretty symmetrical with the
right corner then we can once again just
make a nice crease on both of them and
then we could unfold them now we're
going to take the left side of the
boomerang and we're going to fold it in
half and then once we fold it in half
we're going to take the bottom corner
here at the bottom left corner and fold
it up like this so that this bottom
edges all the way on the right so just
fold it up like that and once it's all
the way on the right then you can just
give it a pinch and then crease it
nicely here as well then you can unfold
it and then we're going to open
everything up again so just take the
edge that we fold it on top and then
just open everything up and flatten it
out and as you'll see the two creases
that we made on top are pointed upwards
like that and the two creases on the
bottom are also pointed upwards towards
the middle like that also now we're
going to take the right side and we're
going to unfold it and this is the part
where some people I think had a little
bit of trouble so I'm going to just draw
on this diamond to make the folds I'm
going to do a little bit easier to see
so I've drawn on the
here and as you'll see the dotted lines
represent Valley folds who are going to
fold upwards like this and the solid
lines represent mountain folds where
it's going to be folded downwards we're
just going to take the top edge here and
I'm going to just push it down and hold
it here with my left thumb what that
does is it lifts up the diamond so that
this edge is now sticking straight up
like that and what I'm going to do I'm
gonna put my right thumb right on this
triangle which is the top of the diamond
on the backside I'm gonna put it right
here and what I'm going to do is I'm
going to push on the triangle so that
this line winds up right on this edge so
I'm just gonna take it and I'm gonna
push it so that line goes right to the
edge like that you say and what that
does is it actually makes a mountain
fold right where I drew that line once
again all I'm doing is just closing the
top pushing on this triangle on the back
and pressing it up against the paper
like that and then I'm going to just
push right here and make a crease then
all I'm going to do is to just hold it
like this and you'll see we have another
triangle which is at the bottom of the
diamond I'm just gonna take my left
thumb and I'm gonna put it right in here
and I'm just gonna press this triangle
also where my thumb is against the paper
that way so just take it and then just
press it like this and then all I'm
going to do is to flatten everything out
there you go now we're ready to move on
to the next part what I'm going to do
now is just fold down this edge of the
paper here so I'm going to fold it down
like this and press it then I'm going to
take the top edge right here and I'm
also going to fold it down now when I do
that what you want to happen is this
little triangle right here you want it
to lift up so I'm gonna actually put my
finger in here and just lift this up and
kind of just press on this horizontal
fold right here like that
this one was folded down now I'm going
to fold this one as you'll see it's kind
of lifting up that little triangle right
there so I'm gonna fold this one down
now also and what it did was it took
this triangle and it actually kind of
folded it down to the left right there
as you'll see all right so I'm just
gonna take my finger to press on that
corner and once again I'm just gonna
flatten everything out now what I'm
going to do is as you'll see we have a
little bit of a pocket right in that
corner we're going to take this corner
all right that we previously pushed
against the paper and I'm going to round
it off a little bit
and it's gonna go right into that pocket
so this whole edge is going to get
folded on top except for this corner
which is going to go in here alright so
we're going to basically start from the
corner round it off like this
and tuck it into that little pocket
right there once it's in that pocket I'm
just gonna push and work my finger in
there and what I do is I kind of just
slide the paper like this at the corner
see I'm just kind of sliding it in and
that allows me to flatten everything out
here so once it's worked in there and
all you need to do is to flatten it out
and again I'm sliding the paper like
this between my fingers so that the
edges go close you might not see them go
edge to edge but that's okay once you
have it like that and you're able to
flatten everything out and the corners
in there then all you need to do is once
again just put it on the table and press
down now all we need to do is to
interlock the corners so we're going to
start with the one on the upper right
here so just hold it like this lift it
up and open these two edges now as
you'll see these are the two corners
that we previously airplane folded in
we're going to open up the right edge
here okay and as you'll see there's two
layers of paper now once again we're
also going to reverse fold this corner
here just like we did with the corners
once we airplane folded them so just
opening up these two and I'm going to
press on this corner here like this so
that you see a triangle and then press
it right into the middle like that and
you'll get this little tab or flap right
here just like that alright so just
opening it and pressing in there like
and then I'm gonna take this flap and
flatten it against the paper now when
you do that just be careful that this
corner doesn't pop out so I'm gonna
flatten this edge back down like this
and then you'll see we have a little
pocket here I'm gonna open this pocket
and I'm gonna tuck this corner in so I'm
gonna round off this corner like this
and tuck it right into that pocket like
that and work your finger and press it
in there and once it's all the way in
then all you need to do is to flatten it
out all right and then you can make a
nice sharp crease with your finger now
so that's one corner and that was the
upper right one okay we're gonna work on
this one and it opens up the other way
so I'm just gonna go like this and open
up these two edges now you'll see we
only have one layer of paper here we're
on the other side it was two and two so
there's one on the left and three on the
right but you're gonna pretend that
these two pieces here are stuck together
this is just one sheet pretend that it's
just one so you're gonna open it up like
this and once again we're gonna tuck
this corner into the middle like this
then we're gonna press right here on
this crease push this in press on this
crease and pinch it and you get another
flap that you can just kind of flatten
against the paper then once again just
close the edge like this then you can
open up this pocket round off the corner
tuck it in work it all the way in there
and make a nice sharp crease and there
you go you've finished the boomerang now
this is actually the back of the
boomerang or the bottom of the boomerang
so we're gonna flip it over like this
and this is how it's going to be thrown
like that alright so congratulations you
finished all the folds for making the
boomerang let's move on to how to throw
it as I mentioned at the end of the
tutorial you want to make sure that we
have this little corner that we tucked
in on the bottom of the boomerang like
this and this is the top and you're
gonna hold it like this so that it looks
like a backwards L with this top corner
slanted downwards like this while this
bottom one slanted upwards to the left
like that
then you gonna put your pointer on the
top angle like this and your thumb here
with the rest of your fingers like that
and you're just gonna flick it outwards
angling it up a little bit maybe at like
a twenty-five thirty degree angle like
that while flicking your wrist
and letting it roll off the tip of your
finger
[Music]
it's very important that you throw it
exactly like I showed like this if you
try to throw it upside down position
like this then it's basically just going
to hit the ground so you can't throw it
like this thank you guys so much for
watching the video if you enjoyed it
please leave a thumbs up or a like down
below and be sure to subscribe by
clicking that subscribe button and the
notification bill I definitely recommend
that you guys make more than one of the
many boomerangs you'll find that some
will fly better than others also you
need to practice for a little bit by
flicking your wrist and throwing you out
like that keeping the boomerang and I
spin if you do want to film yourself
throwing and catching it doing some
trick shots leave me a comment below or
a link to your video and I'll check it
out in my feature in my next video I did
go on a trip out of the country back in
July and I had about five thousand
dollars worth of stuff stolen my cameras
and my laptop but I did get a new camera
and I did get a new laptop here so
thankfully that's taken care of I'm able
to make some videos now so looking
forward to it I was thinking of making a
mini super boomerang video where I show
how to take two of them together and
throw it like I did on my other channel
the only thing is I found that it
doesn't work as well with the mini
boomerang but it does work so I was
thinking of doing that or I was also
doing a left-handed boomerang tutorials
so let me know if you want to see that
in the comments below and I'll see you
next time thanks so much for watching